online time on the telephone
as well as on video but it's good to see
you in person again
and uh
we've been in close and frequent
communication throughout this conflict
from the very beginning but particularly
uh is particularly meaningful to talk
with another person look each other in
the eye
because leadership through this terrible
crisis has inspired
the Ukrainian people as you have done Mr
President and the American people in the
entire world
this visit to Washington your first trip
outside Ukraine since February comes as
President Putin has escalated his
attacks his brutal attacks
targeting critical infrastructure to
make life as hard as possible
for not only Innocent ukrainians but
children and young children everything
from orphanages to schools it's just
outrages what he's doing
and we've uh as we've heard into the as
we head in a New Year it's important for
the American people and for the world to
hear directly from you Mr President
about Ukraine's fight and the need to
continue to stand together through 2023.
this visit also falls on the 300-day
mark of Russia's brutal invasion of
Ukraine
300 days since Putin launched an
unprovoked unjustified all-out assault
on the Free People of Ukraine
300 days of Ukrainian people showing
Russia and the world their steel
backbone their love of country and their
unbreakable determination and I
emphasize unbreakable determination to
choose their own path
to Ukrainian people
I say to them all you have demonstrated
you've shown your strong stand against
aggression in the face of the Imperial
appetites of autocrats who wrongfully
believe you might you might they they
might be able to make might right and
they're not able to do it thus far
they've not they've stood alone
you know and you've have but you haven't
stood alone you have had significant
significant help we've never stand alone
you will never stand alone when
Ukraine's Freedom was threatened the
American people like Generations
Americans before us did not hesitate
the support from all across this country
Americans of every Walk of Life
Democrats and Republicans alike had the
resources and the to rebound and
resounding United Way to do provide
unequivocal and unbending support for
Ukraine because we understand in our
bones that Ukraine's fight is part of
something much bigger
the American people know that if we
stand by in the face of Sergeant blatant
attacks on Liberty and democracy and the
core principles of sovereignty and
territorial Integrity the world would
surely face worse consequences
as I said when Putin rolled his tanks in
the Ukraine in February American
American people are prepared to have us
stand up to bullies stand up for Freedom
that's who we are as Americans and
that's exactly what we've done
even before The Invasion began and Putin
threatened Ukraine by building up his
forces we helped make sure Ukraine would
be prepared to defend itself even before
they crossed into Ukraine we provide a
steady stream of defensive weapons
including air defense systems and
artillery ammunition and so much more
we've not done it alone
from the very beginning the United
States rallied allies and partners from
around the world to stand strong with
Ukraine and impose unprecedented and I
emphasize unprecedented sanctions and
Export controls on Russia making it
harder for the Kremlin to wage this
brutal War
than 50 Nations have committed nearly 2
000 tanks and other armored vehicles
more than 800 artillery systems more
than 2 million rounds of artillery
ammunition and more more than 50
Advanced multiple rocket launching
systems and I ship and anti and air
defense systems all to strengthen
Ukraine
together we provided billions of dollars
in direct budgetary support
to make sure the Ukrainian government
can keep providing basic fundamental
services to the Iranian people like
Health Care education and emergency
personnel
this includes another two billion
dollars that in direct budget support
from the American people at the World
Bank distributed earlier this week
we provide a humanitarian assistance to
help the millions of ukrainians who have
been forced to flee their homes because
of Putin's inhumane brutal War
communities across Europe have opened
their hearts and their homes to help
ukrainians in need
the United States has been proud to
welcome more than 221 thousand
ukrainians seeking Refuge since March of
2022 including as part of uniting for
Ukraine as part of our United Ukraine
program
and today usaid is committing more than
374 million dollars in urgently
humanitarian assistance for Ukraine
this will provide food and cash
assistance for more than 1.5 million
Ukrainian people as well as Access to
Health Care safe drinking water and help
stay warm in the winter
to more than for more than 2.5 million
ukrainians the United States and our
allies and partners around the world
have delivered a broad range of
assistance at historic speed and has
been critical to bolstering Ukraine's
success thus far
Ukraine has won the Battle of Kiev has
won the Battle of Pearson has won the
Battle of kharkiv Ukraine has defied
Russia's expectations at every single
turn
and president polensky you have made it
clear that he is uh open to pursuing uh
um well let me put it this way he's not
open but you're open to pursuing peace
you're open to pursuing a just peace we
also know that Putin has no intention no
intention of stopping this cruel War and
the United States is committed to
ensuring that the brave Ukrainian people
can continue continue to defend their
country against Russian aggressions as
long as it takes and I want to thank the
members of Congress and they're for the
broad bipartisan support to Ukraine and
I look forward to signing the Omnibus
Omnibus Bill soon which includes 45
billion dollars 45 billion dollars in
additional funding for Ukraine
I'll also sign in law the National
Defense authorization Act
which includes author authorities for to
make it easier for the Department of
Defense to procure critical Munitions
and defense materials for Ukraine and
other key materials to strengthen our
national security today I'm announcing
the next tranche of our security
assistance Ukraine
1.85 billion dollar package of security
assistance that includes both direct
transfers of equipment to the Ukraine
needs as well as contracts to supply
ammunition Ukraine will need in the
months ahead for its artillery its tanks
and its rocket launchers
critically in addition to these new
capabilities like Precision aerial
Munitions the package will include a
patriot missile battery which will and
one which will train Ukrainian forces to
operate as part of the ongoing effort to
help bolster Ukraine's air defense
this could take some time to complete
the necessary training with the Patriot
battery will be another critical asset
for Ukraine as it defends itself against
Russian aggression
all together today's new security
assistance with humanitarian funding
amounts to 2.2 billion dollars in
Digital support for the Ukrainian people
we should be clear about what Russia is
doing
it is a purposefully attacking Ukraine's
critical infrastructure destroying the
system to provide heat and light to
Ukrainian people during the coldest
darkest part of the year
Russia is using winter as a weapon
freezing people starving people cutting
them off from one another
it's the latest example of the
outrageous atrocities the Russian forces
are committed against innocent Ukrainian
civilians children and their families
and the United States is working
together or the allies and partners to
provide critical equipment to help
Ukraine make emergency repairs to their
power transmission systems and
strengthen the stability of Ukraine's
Grid in the face of Russia's targeted
attacks we're also working to hold
Russia accountable including efforts in
Congress that will make it easier to
seek Justice for Russia's war crimes in
Ukraine let me close with this
tonight is the fourth night's a night of
Hanukkah a time when Jewish people
around the world president zielinski and
many of the families among them honor
the Timeless Miracle the small band of
warriors fighting for their values and
their freedom against a much larger Foe
and how they endured and how they
overcame
how the flame of Faith with only enough
oil for one day burned brightly for
eight days
The Story of Survival and resilience
that reminds us that the coldest days of
the year that light will always Prevail
over darkness and hope drives away
despair
and that the human spirit is
unconquerable as long as there are good
people willing to do what is right
this year has brought so much needless
suffering and loss to the Ukrainian
people
but I want you to know president
zielinski I want you to know that all
the people of Ukraine to know as well
the American people have been with you
every step of the way and we will stay
with you we will stay with you for as
long as it takes
what you're doing
what you've achieved it matters not just
the Ukraine but to the entire world
and together I have no doubt we'll keep
the flame of Liberty Burning Bright
and the light will remain and Prevail
over the darkness thank you for being
here Mr President we're going to stand
with you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
I am here today
significantly
to create
the terrorists
[Music]
regardless of changes
foreign
[Music]
specific steps what America can do to
help people implement this formal
assignments
Integrity of the company
capabilities
thank you for your attention to all of
these issues glory to Ukraine
thank you very much Mr President we're
going to take a questions from four
different reporters and those start with
Alex of Yahoo news
thank you Mr President
um in 20 2022 you presided over a
bipartisan International Coalition to
support Ukraine how will you keep that
Coalition from fraying in 2023 and
president zielinski welcome to
Washington on this beautiful winter day
what is your message to the American
people
we've answered your questions first uh
um I'm not at all worried about holding
the alliance together NATO and Europe
Union
um
I assume this is simultaneous
all right
okay I've never seen NATO or the EU more
united about anything at all and I see
no sign of there being any change
we all know what's at stake here our
European Partners all the more so they
fully understand it this is about we've
never seen a major invasion of a
European country since World War II and
they see no signs that Putin is going to
do anything to change that unless we
resist and we help the ukrainians resist
we all know what's at stake the very
idea of sovereignty the U.N Charter
Putin thought he would weaken NATO
instead he strengthened NATO I once said
to him that we talk about the he wanted
to see the uh you know Europe end up
being uh
um divided uh the uh and instead what
did he do he produced a more united
Europe with Sweden and uh Finland
joining so I don't see any reason to
believe there'll be any less than of
support and as we reach out to our NATO
allies our secretary of defense and the
Secretary of State we get continued
support not only there but also from
around the world from Japan and many
other countries as well so I feel very
good about the solidarity of support for
Ukraine
thank you for your question thank you
very much you asked me what are the
messages
I think I will tell you very simple
things which are very important for me
and I and I think so that we have
the same values and the same
understanding of the life
the sense of the life my message
I wish you peace
I think that the main thing
and you understand it only when the war
in your country
when somebody like these terrorists from
Russia
come to your houses
and I wish you to see your children
alive
and adults
and I wish you to see your children and
they will go to you know what's this
and to see their children
I I think that is the main thing what I
can wish you
and of course to be together with us
generally
because we really fight for our common
Victory against this tyranny
that is real life
and we will win
and I really want
win together
thanks so much
not want sorry I'm sure
call on one of your people
first person yeah
yeah thank you Dimitri an option to
Ukrainian television oh president
zelinski President Biden I got a
question to both of you but firstly as
Ukrainian and I mean it I want to thank
United States for supporting my country
and you know my family is in Ukraine and
I definitely understand there will not
be alive today if America will not
support my country both political and
militarily so thank you for this
and as of my question away enter a new
phase of this war and uh you definitely
discussed today which path to choose uh
how the war could come to an end and
what's next will it turn into a new
contrapensive or some kind of peace
talks so Mr Biden Mrs landscape could
you share your vision what's the fair
way to end this war and how do you
understand these words Fair peace thank
you
my view you're a guy I think we have oh
yeah I see it I see although I like it
very much already
um
you have started this question
I'm sorry I sometimes I switch on my
native language
you have started by stating that your
family is in cave and without the
assistance of the United States
this is absolutely true the U.S
leadership in this assistance is
I would like to remind you that your
family will be in danger
without the Armed Forces of Ukraine
which is very important
that concerns your questions to say uh
what would you like to hear
just peace I don't know I don't know
what just this is it's a very
philosophical description if there is a
to just War I don't know it was
nighttime
and still the sovereign
I don't know how to describe that
because we are in the White House and I
can't find the proper language so these
Inhumans I would say
let me respond I I think we have the we
share the exact same vision
and uh that uh free independent
prosperous and secure Ukraine is
division
we both want this war to end we both
want it to end
and as I've said uh uh it could end a
day if Putin had any dignity at all and
did the right thing and just said pulled
out
but that's not going to happen not going
to happen it's not going to happen now
so what comes next we talked about today
was we're going to continue helping
crane succeed on the battlefield it can
succeed in the battlefield with our help
and the help of our European allies and
others so that if and when President
zielinski is ready to talk with the
Russians he will be able to succeed as
well because he will have won on the
battlefield
and uh
um you know I I don't think we should
underestimate the impact this war is
having on Russia and the losses they're
suffering and you saw just I think it
was two days ago Putin saying that this
is much tougher than he thought he
thought he could break NATO he thought
he could break the West he thought he
could break the alliance he thought he
could be welcomed by the Ukrainian
people that were russian-speaking he was
wrong wrong and wrong he continues to be
wrong the sooner he makes it it's clear
that he cannot possibly win this war
that's when the time we have to put this
president in a position to be able to
decide how he wants the war to
my turn huh
Bliss yeah Phil madly uh Mattingly of
CNN
thank you Mr President welcome Mr
President Mr President to start with you
um your advisors often talk about how
important how critically important you
view face-to-face interaction I'm
wondering after spending two plus hours
face to face with President zielinski uh
what you learned or what you took from
the meeting that perhaps you couldn't
glean or learn in the phone calls or
video conferences and somewhat tied to
that was there any discussion related to
the U.S assessment that Russia would not
take escalatory action
now that Patriots are being sent will be
a patriot battery will be delivered let
me answer the first question the first
part of your question
you know I get kitted for saying that
there's all politics is personal
it's all about looking someone in the
eye and I mean it sincerely I don't
think there's any any substitute for
sitting down face to face with a friend
or a foe and looking them in the eye
and that's exactly uh what's happened at
this moment we've done that more than
once we're going to continue to do it
and the winner is setting in and Putin
is uh increasingly going after civilian
targets and women and children
orphanages this guy is
well
but but he's going to fail and he's
going to fail he's already failed
because he now knows that there's no way
he's ever going to occupy all of Ukraine
there's no way in which he's going to be
accepted by the Ukrainian people and so
uh he's failed in the past and was very
important for him and everyone else to
see the president of zelinski and I are
united two countries together to make
sure he cannot succeed and I think I may
be mistaken but I know I judge every
Leader by the way they what they say to
me the consistency and look at me now
this guy has in his to his very soul
is who he says he is it's clear who he
is he's willing to give his life for his
country and all the folks that were with
came with him today and so I think it's
uh he's
important for him to know we are going
to do everything in our power everything
in our power to see that he succeeds
what was the second part of your
question I just asked if you discussed
how the U.S calculated the escalatory
effect of sending a patriot missile
battery to Ukraine I did not discuss
that at all with the with the president
but I we do not it's a defensive system
it's the defensive weapon system it's
not escalatory it's defensive and it's
easy to uh not and we'd love to not have
to have them use it just stop the
attacks
president zielinski again welcome I I
mentioned earlier that you wanted to
make this trip uh for a while now why
now and also can you tell me what you
think the message you are sending to
President Putin is given the fact that
24 hours ago you were on the ground in
the front lines with artillery echoing
behind you and now you find yourself in
the White House standing next to the
president
thank you very much for your question
yes to
yeah
what is the message for Putin yesterday
I am standing here in the United States
with President Biden on the same Podium
because I respect him as a person as a
president as a human being for his
position and for me this is a historic
moment I can send messages to President
Biden for example if it's not serious
you said what's going to happen after
Patriots are installed after that we
will send another signal to President
Biden that we would like to get more
patriots
we are in war I'm sorry I'm really sorry
that is my appreciation
President Putin
in 2019
um
we had a Normandy meeting in 2019 I
became the president of Ukraine and at
that time we were sending maximum
messages to President Putin telling him
that there shouldn't be a full-scale
Innovation to stop aggression to renew
our territory territorial Integrity
diplomatic Solutions well God forbid we
should not have a full-scale war at that
time he said it won't happen he was
lying so what kind of message I can send
him after he actually yeah
destroyed our life is destroying our
life he can even go further somewhere
where the Soviet Union stayed before
this so he might want to innovate those
territories too I believe that there is
something absolutely Immortal about his
inadequate approach to the world why we
need to send him a message he needs to
be interested in getting attention from
the world because he is not the subject
of civilized people he should be
interested in trying to save something
of his culture and history of his
country so that's his problem now
this will be the last question
when the full Invasion started U.S
officials said that Ukraine
cannot receive Petros because as you
said it might be unnecessary escalation
and now it is happening right now today
it is happening
um and now Ukraine desperately needs
more capabilities including long-range
missiles uh attackums maybe I sound
naive but can we make a long story short
and give Ukraine all capabilities it
needs and liberate all territories
around us sooner than later thank you
I'm sorry
his answer is yes
[Laughter]
I agree
let me be straightforward with you here
look
the fact is that uh it was important to
remember
that before Russia invaded
we had dedicated an enormous amount of
security assistance Ukraine
and uh and we've given Ukraine what they
needed when they needed to defend
themselves
and since the invasion that has resulted
more than 20 billion dollars in terms of
security assistance
just today I approved another 1.8
billion dollars in additional assistance
Ukraine for it to succeed on the
battlefield
and we're focused on working with allies
and partners to generate capability in
four key areas air defense as no as we
know today the Patriot is the best of
that
secondly is to uh and we're looking to
do more
we provided hundreds of advanced
artillery systems and dozens of from
dozens of countries
thirdly we've worked with Partners to
get Ukraine tanks and other armored
vehicles
and fourthly we've announced today
another 200 000 rounds of additional
ammunition
and you say why don't we just give
Ukraine everything there is to give
for two reasons one there's an entire
Alliance that is critical to stay with
Ukraine and the idea that we would give
Ukraine material that is a fundamentally
different than it's already going there
would have a prospect of breaking up
NATO and breaking up the European Union
and the rest of the world we're going to
give Ukraine what it needs to be able to
defend itself to be able to succeed and
succeed in the battlefield and the other
piece of this is you may recall one of
the reasons why
I have spent well I won't tell you the
calculation but I've spent several
hundred hours face to face
with our European allies in the heads of
state of those countries and making the
case as to why it was overwhelming their
interest that they continue to support
Ukraine they understand it fully but
they're not looking to go to war with
Russia they're not looking for a third
world war and I think they can all be
avoided by making sure the Ukraine is
able to succeed in the battlefield so
anyway there's more to say but I
probably already said too much
thank you
well thank you all very very much
appreciate your time and attention and
as I said Mr President you don't have to
worry uh we are staying with Ukraine as
long as Ukraine is there thank you all
thank you so much
all the best ladies and Gentlemen please
remain in your seats until the official
delegations have departed thank you